hola buenas noches
bueno pues es un gran gusto estar ante
todos ustedes muy emocionado de escuchar
la plática de todos mis compañeros que
han estado pues contando sus historias
que son historias muy interesantes cada
una de ellas y la del santo y la
historia del hijo del santo también
tienen pues mucho mucho de interés
y me llamó mucho la atención la plática
de teo del futbolista brasileño porque
él habló de los sueños yo regularmente
cuando hago o doy mis pláticas mis
conferencias que son motivacionales
regularmente mi conferencia se llama
sueños entonces dije me estás copiando
teo
que está pasando
me quise traer un laboratorio pero nada
más me consiguieron esta mesa
pero quiero platicarles
sobre todo pues como inicia esta
historia
los sueños
en mí son muy importantes y mi padre
inició su carrera con un sueño cuando
era niño muchos de ustedes saben que él
nació en tulancingo hidalgo fue un niño
muy humilde un niño que tuvo que pasar
pues muchas penalidades pero cuando
llegó a la ciudad de mexico se empezó a
involucrar con el deporte con el fútbol
americano le gustaba jugar béisbol y de
pronto por ahí descubrió la lucha libre
en un lugar que se llamaba el casino de
policía donde entrenaban muchos policías
y también entrenaban jóvenes que no eran
policías pero entrenaban jujitsu y todas
las artes marciales y la lucha libre y
mi padre bueno pues
como todas las historias de los
triunfadores empezó un camino difícil
primero empezó a luchar con su nombre
verdadero todos sabemos que él era
rodolfo guzmán y se puso rudy guzmán
empezó a luchar pero él se daba cuenta
que no pasaba nada como rudy guzmán
después se intentó enmascarar ya estaba
de moda ponerse una máscara estaban
algunos luchadores enmascarados y probó
probó suerte con otros nombres hasta que
se convirtió en el santo cuando él se
convierte en el santo se da cuenta de
que empieza a tener mucha fama de que le
está yendo muy bien en su carrera
tan es tan grande su popular popularidad
que hace una historieta en los años de
1952 se inició la historieta y ahí nace
santo el enmascarado de plata la
historieta lo hace un superhéroe
un superhéroe porque el santo allí puede
ser el defensor de los débiles
y el justiciero y la la historieta es la
plataforma para que el santo llegue al
cine pero lamentablemente cuando la
gente empieza a tener éxito pues recibe
muchas críticas y descalificaciones en
fin pero él nunca nunca hizo caso
y logro sus sueños el santo también se
radio de gente que era muy soñadora
empezó a hacer cine y su cine que era
catalogado como churros mexicanos en
europa
se considera un cine de culto lo cual a
él ya no le tocó saber esto pero
debe de llenarnos de orgullo a los que a
quienes admiramos al santo
y en estas películas pues el santo como
les mencioné estaba rodeado de gente
soñadora sus productores los guionistas
y el santo se adelantó a la tecnología
cuando veíamos sus películas no podíamos
creer que hubiera un laboratorio que
hubiera una una pantalla en donde el
santo pudiera hablar con el profesor
orlov se acuerdan de sant o llamando a
blue demon santo llamando a blue demon
es urgente blue es urgente eso ahora lo
podemos hacer con incluso ya hay relojes
por los cuales podemos hablar tenemos
videoconferencias tenemos un gps nuestro
auto el santo traía su pantalla para
llegar a los lugares donde tenía que
llegar y esta tecnología que también hoy
se ha hablado de tecnología ha sido ya
es una es una realidad
y la verdad pues eso es es algo que a mi
padre le debe enorgullecer mucho porque
pues fue otro sueño otro sueño que el
santo que el santo cumplió perdón lo que
estoy haciendo
tengo mis imágenes pero como se estaba
yendo la luz
mejor me las llevo en la mano y bueno
pues del santo como les mencionó fue un
superhéroe en las historietas y en el
cine pero yo considero que el santo como
ser humano también fue un héroe y yo
quisiera preguntarle si me lo permiten a
algunos de ustedes me voy a tomarla yo
soy ya ya puse el desorden pero a ver
aquí nuestro amigo que estaba viendo el
celular cómo te llamas amigo mario con
mario mario cómo estás mario para ti qué
significa ser un héroe
alguien que salva del mal a una persona
buena muy bien mario muchas gracias
quien más me podría contestar con esa
luz en los ojos no veo bien a ver una
chica o la nena cómo te llamas llenarte
como ganarte ganarte cómo estás
jan arte para ti que es que es un héroe
no un superhéroe un héroe
alguien que busca el bien para los demás
no
sobresalir él mismo muy bien muchas
gracias alguien más me quiere dar su
opinión usted tiene cara así como que
quiere contestar para ti que es ser un
héroe es alguien que sin pensarlo hace
algo algo bueno por alguien más hay
excelente señor se la voy a cambiar a
usted como se llama ricardo otro debe
haber usted es un hombre sabio dígame un
héroe nace o se hace se hace
usted cree que un héroe se hace con la
vida usted amigo igual se hace se hace a
ver
a ver usted está muy seria un héroe nace
o se hace se hace se hace bueno hay
alguien que opine diferente
yo creo que nace y no todas las personas
pueden ser héroes día a día cualquier
persona que se ponga una meta y que y
que la persiga puede ser su propio héroe
muy bien muchas gracias
bueno pues de esto me gusta
preguntárselo porque bueno hay
diferentes opiniones pero finalmente un
héroe un héroes
para todos nosotros quizás es alguien
que se sacrifican que tiene fortaleza
que es competitivo que es auténtico
alguien que es auténtico que tiene fe
que tiene compromiso que tiene pasión
pasión por lo que hacemos cuando hacemos
algo con pasión es muy gratificante
hace poco una amiga mía cuando ya nos va
a decir mi edad pero cuando llega la
crisis de los 50 años no sé qué pasó en
mí y no sé si les ha pasado a ustedes
que ya van a los 50 y saben que me dijo
ya ponte a trabajar
y primero me ofendí le dije oye qué te
pasa toda la vida y trabajado si algo me
caractericé soy muy trabajador me
encanta mi trabajo me dijo no te lo has
vivido 35 años divirtiéndote haciendo te
haciendo lo que te guste y aparte te
pagan y ahí me di cuenta que realmente
era una bendición porque todo lo que yo
hago lo hago con mucha pasión
yo crecí en un núcleo familia familiar
muy bonito mi familia mis padres fueron
maravillosos y quiero presumir les que
mi mamá yo siempre digo que tuvo el 50%
del éxito del santo porque lo apoyo
desde que él era rudy guzmán que eran
gente muy humilde y de pronto el santo
pues se convirtió en alguien muy famoso
y mi mamá siempre estuvo con él
apoyándolo nunca los celo desde después
de verlo con lorena veladas que es con
sasha montenegro y con todas estas
bellezas mi mamá siempre siempre estuvo
a su lado
y bueno pues frío fue un niño muy
afortunado soy el menor de diez hermanos
y fue un niño pues por qué no decirlo
fui consentido pero siempre me enseñaron
valores y principios morales
y pensé que la vida era maravillosa que
la vida era color de rosa y que yo iba a
cumplir todos mis sueños también desde
niño fui muy soñador y mi papá y mi mamá
siempre me apoyaron pero cuando yo tenía
19 años que ingresé a la universidad el
primer golpe que me dio la vida fue la
muerte de mi mamá a los 19 años
y eso fracturó mi familia fue algo muy
duro la verdad
sin embargo la vida tenía que seguir
seguí en la universidad mi papá no
quería que luchar hasta que no me
titulará entonces pues teníamos allí
algunas discusiones finalmente me me
hace un examen un examen a puerta
cerrada para ver mi capacidad en el ring
y me pregunta porque yo ya estaba
luchando escondidas estudiaba y luchaba
a escondidas de él entonces me descubrió
y nos enojamos y entonces me dijo bueno
y con qué nombre luchas y le dije
orgullosamente yo yo me llamo korac papá
qué es eso
le dije korac es en una historieta el
hijo de tarzán no no no mi hijito ese
nombre está horrible mejor ponte el hijo
del santo y me quedé helado le dije como
mi hijo si mejor el hijo de tarzán dos
mejores hijos del santo me dijo que
andas si no que le pides a tarzán cuando
él me dijo eso yo no puedo decirle no
este imagínense el compromiso pero dije
si él me lo está autorizando y si él
confía en mí yo voy a lograr mis
objetivos entonces debute como el hijo
del santo me empezó a ir muy bien pero
como mencionen no a todos les caemos
bien entonces la prensa decía que yo era
malo en el ring que nunca segundas
partes fueron buenas que mi papá me
debería de meter a entrenar y mi papá me
dijo no escuches las críticas ni tampoco
cuando te adulan cree en ti ten fe en ti
cree en tus sueños y adelante
bueno aquí aquí quiero quiero hacer una
analogía brevemente de la lucha libre
con la vida en la lucha libre hay
técnicos y hay malos o hay rudos y
buenos igual que en la vida los rivales
siempre nos quieren ver en la lona en la
vida también nos quieren ver en él
tirados y cuando te tienen en el suelo
pues nadie te ayuda a levantar sino que
al contrario quieren hundirte
y yo he aprendido esto de la lucha libre
que en la vida también hay que
levantarse hay que hay que salir
adelante
y bueno pues no ha sido fácil ustedes
pueden pensar el hijo del santo nació no
con pañales de seda tuvo la mesa puesta
créanme que no ser el hijo del santo no
es fácil ha sido mucho sacrificio un
gran compromiso
y yo soy igual que todos ustedes
entonces quiero demostrarles que soy una
persona igual que ustedes me voy a
quitar la máscara
no importa que me la quite
no importa 2 100 me la quito si me la
quita híjole qué malo eres malvado
me la voy a quitar para que vean que soy
igual que usted es un ser humano normal
porque hago esto porque si yo hubiera
llegado aquí sin máscara nadie me conoce
nadie me saludan nadie pues me voltea a
ver bueno no sé tal vez como estoy guapo
tal vez sí pero entonces yo sería uno
más igual que ustedes un espectador
estaría aquí sentado no les puedo
mostrar mi verdadero rostro pero soy una
persona normal que tiene problemas que
sufre que si se poncha la llanta del
auto me tengo que bajar a cambiarla que
si me quedé sin gasolina pues tengo que
remediarlo si llueve me mojo si voy al
súper pues tengo que hacer fila si voy
al cine si yo llevo una vida una doble
vida y es eso también es un sacrificio
porque a veces no puede ir a la escuela
de mis hijos porque saben que el papá de
mis hijos es el hijo del santo entonces
si voy pues me expongo a que me tomen
fotos en fin
este ejercicio lo hago para que pues
para demostrarles que soy tan normal
como ustedes pero cuando yo me pongo
esta máscara
me transformo
llega en mí una energía de pasión de
entrega de amor por este personaje muy
bonito de verdad
[Música]
otra vez
no pudieron ver nada bueno
pues es poco el tiempo no sé cómo vamos
de tiempo pero
he aprendido también que hay competencia
que hay luchadores que quieren tu lugar
como en la vida vuelvo a la analogía de
la vida y de la lucha todos quieren tu
lugar o los envidiosos no quieren que
tengas lo que tienen ni lo quieren ellos
pero lo que no quieren es que tú
triunfes entonces pues lamentablemente
tenemos que luchar por nuestros ideales
salir adelante y
regularmente nosotros como personas la
mayoría de los seres humanos buscamos el
éxito
pues buscamos el éxito por ahí donde
está el éxito y el éxito está dentro de
nosotros eso es lo que yo pienso está
dentro de nuestro de nuestro corazón y
si nosotros logramos unir nuestro
corazón con nuestra mente si decretamos
si somos positivos seguramente vamos a
lograr nuestros sueños hacerlos realidad
y hay un hay una hay una estrella
interna que tenemos todos dentro de
nosotros y esta estrella ya me brinqué
todas las hojas que cosas
esta estrella tiene cinco puntas y pues
una de ellas habla de la comunicación de
la comunicación que tenemos que tener
con nuestro yo interno contra nuestro yo
interior
y amor por nosotros tener una buena
actitud de una actitud positiva en la
vida una buena autoestima una alta
autoestima tener ambiciones que son las
metas que queremos cumplir no no es malo
ser ambicioso en el buen sentido pero
hay que trabajar todos tenemos que
trabajar yo lo único que quiero
compartir con ustedes es que crean en
sus sueños sobre todo los más jovencitos
que están iniciando si quieren ser
comunicólogos si quieren ser psicólogos
crean en ustedes crean en sus sueños y
estoy seguro que lo van a lograr y para
terminar les quiero practicar brevemente
cuánto tiempo tengo
ya se acabó bueno esta manzana también
tiene su historia bueno a su hermanita
porque ésta todavía no había una manzana
en un árbol y preguntaba siempre a las
manzanas que eran más maduras que es una
estrella
y una manzana le dijo una estrella es
una luz en el firmamento y la manzanita
pues no entendía
pasó el tiempo se acercó a otra manzana
y le dijo oye manzana y tú dime que es
una estrella yo quiero saber qué es una
estrella
pues una estrella es la
algo que admiran los enamorados y
tampoco se convencía entonces pues se
fue así por la vida preguntando que era
una estrella que era una estrella y
cuando esta manzana maduro se cayó del
árbol pero cayó en una roca y se partió
en dos y saben que descubrió
bueno esta manzana está un poco verde
pero descubrió no sé sí
bueno hagan este ejercicio todas las
manzanitas tienen una estrella en medio
está un poco verde y esa misma estrella
es la que nosotros llevamos en nuestro
corazón
así es que pues sueñen con mucho
entusiasmo no dejen de soñar nunca y
crean en ustedes y logren todos sus
sueños gracias por su atención me
encantó estar con ustedes
y pues
un honor estar a clientes gracias
[Aplausos]